baby what's happening what's going on
it's over between us it's over between
us yeah oh my god what are we gonna do
Ashton Kutcher and Mila Kunis had a
little fun with the tabloid rumors after
they got an advanced look at a new cover
that proclaims it's over I felt
obligated you felt suffocated by me oh I
was just so overbearing well tonight
also what else is going on I took the
kids oh you took the kids I don't get
the kids anymore well I get a very dark
secret exposed oh my gosh what was the
dark secret that's been really dark
Ashton shared that video to Instagram or
writing in the caption InTouch Weekly
have fun selling magazines this week
maybe next week my wife will be having
twins for the third time but who's
counting and he got a lot of friendly
support in the comments everyone from
Dax Shepard to Demi Lovato and even his
ex stepdaughter Rumer Willis weighed in
I read the comments and you try to
listen to that 1% of people that
actually have your best interest in mind
the truth is I post like the things that
I post in into public social media I do
so very intently
well it seems safe to say Ashton and
Mila aren't over in fact they kind of
seem stronger than ever we're still in
love like it's a you hype I would you
still like each other needs to like your
kid at the end of the night it's over
between us it's over between those